we are learning new details about the
investigation into the events
surrounding the 2020 election and the
select committee is investigating
january 6 is asking ivanka trump to tell
them what she saw and heard in the white
house before during and after the
assault on the capitol scott mcfarland
has more on all of it from capitol hill
in a letter to the former first daughter
the january 6 committee says it wants to
talk especially about a phone call she
heard the panel wants to know more about
the testimony to the committee involving
mr trump's call to mike pence from the
oval office the morning before the u.s
capitol attack
urging him to block certification of
president biden's victory she has
information that would help us get a
clearer picture as well as information
the pres former president may have
received from his own legal staff that
what
was being proposed was unconstitutional
in its letter the committee says it's
learned some white house aides saw
ivanka trump's intervention to get her
father to address the lawlessness and
violence we love you you're very special
the committee says it also wants to know
about outtakes of donald trump's january
6 video message to rioters in which the
committee says it has information
suggesting he did not ask them to leave
and the letter says some white house
aides have told the committee trump did
wish to go to the capitol with the crowd
that day i believe it was the biggest
crowd i've ever spoken to it was massive
i'm not talking about the people that
walk down to the capitol i'm talking
about the people that we were watching i
felt that was going to happen
at the rally or whatever you want to
call it at the people listening to the
speeches from a lot of different people
a spokesperson for ivanka trump did not
address whether she'd comply writing as
she publicly stated that day at 3 15 p.m
any security breach or disrespect to our
law enforcement is unacceptable the
committee's request comes the same day
atlanta's top prosecutor requested a
special grand jury to help investigate
whether the former president interfered
with georgia's 2020 election results the
former president has been under scrutiny
for his post-election call to the
secretary of state during which he made
this request all i want to do is this i
just want to find
11
780
votes
in a statement the former president says
that phone call was perfect and he says
that special grand jury should instead
be investigating what he falsely claims
is large-scale voter fraud that took
place in georgia
in the meantime a member of the house
select january 6 committee tells me they
need time to go through a potential load
of documents from the white house from
the national archives now that they've
been cleared to do so by the supreme
court
gail
scott thank you